they clone Tyrone is one of the weirdest
films I've seen in a long time and has
the best fried chicken ad since Jones
barbecue I'm not let one of my foot
Specialists or myself perform our magic
look at that they look wonderful in this
completely absurd film about the
government controlling us through fried
chicken and grape drink is a blistering
commentary on Society racism and of
course the dangers of cloning I'm not
the Clone you're the Clone in this video
we'll be taking a deep dive into the
ending the government's plan to
assimilate and the introduction of
Tyrone so grab a drumstick and relax
because here we go meet Fontaine at Down
and Out drug dealer struggling to
survive in the Cutthroat world of the
Glen it's never mentioned where exactly
the Glen is the license plates merely
state that it's a swell Place ironic
since it couldn't be further from but
the question of where they are is also
followed by when they are you have
things like flip phones CDs and a beeper
Emporium suggesting we could be in the
early 2000s yet characters will talk
about more recent events like Obama as
President or blockchain setting it
closer to present day I would have voted
for Obama for a third term if I could
this is all part of the Absurd aesthetic
of the film which I thought was almost
as refreshing as a delicious Suma soda
speaking of which the film's first image
is that of a white man's eyes watching
over a group of black men foreshadowing
how the white controlled surveillance
State keeps a constant watch over the
predominantly black neighborhood of the
Glen when Fontaine finds out one of his
dealers a pimp by the name of slick
Charles is late on his payments he pays
him a visit now slick Charles says that
the latest batch he got just ain't hit
and right and if you know the big twist
of the movie you'll understand why more
on that in a bit the life of a drug
dealer ain't easy in the Glen and
Fontaine is gunned down by Rival Dealer
Isaac but surprisingly Fontaine wakes up
good as new the next day now when I was
first watching this movie I thought we
were dealing with a groundhog day type
situation Fontaine will wake up every
morning go through the paces and and try
to figure out what's going on but they
cloned Tyrone is a little different
unlike Phil in Groundhog Day Fontaine
has no recollection of the events of the
previous day but goes through many of
the same sequences of events like weight
training and buying beer and scratch
tickets at the convenience store but
things start to get strange for Fontaine
as he sees a bloody man get picked up by
an SUV with local homeless man by the
name of frog stating wizard again in
literature frogs often symbolize ancient
wisdom and knowledge he may be a drunk
homeless guy but he seems to be the only
person who knows what's going on in town
his reference to The Wizard of Oz is apt
considering Fontaine is still in our
metaphorical Kansas The Glenn but soon
we'll find out that his world is being
controlled by a seemingly all-powerful
force with aspirations of Total Control
when Fontaine arrives yet again to ask
for his money from slick Charles Charles
can't believe he's alive you should be
breathing through some tombs right now
Charles saw him shot up just yesterday
how was he he's still here this is where
woman of the night yo-yo comes in she
recognized the car the perps who shot
Fontaine and takes them to it where
Fontaine just so happens to see this
same black SUV he saw outside the
convenience store so he does the only
rational thing and breaks into the
neighboring home but to their surprise
it's completely empty that is of course
if you don't count the super weird break
room with a TV playing Bloodsport in the
background now a creepy house like this
wouldn't be complete without a secret
elevator leading down to a Walter White
lap facility goddamn right here we find
a substance that looks to be cocaine but
isn't quite this is compound h a
compound developed by the government and
injected into various products like
cocaine Fried Chicken hair cream and
grape drink to control the black
population as much of the film delves
into Fontaine slick Charles and yo-yo
getting to the bottom of this mystery
just like a Nancy Drew novel we don't
get any answers until Fontaine devises a
plan to Rally alongside his rival drug
dealer to take on the secret all white
scientists who live underneath the city
experimenting on African Americans but
to understand how and why all of this
has happened we have to fast forward to
the biggest Twist of the film the lead
geneticist of this whole operation is
none other than Fontaine himself or
should I say an older version but why
would he turn against his people why
would he work with the very people who
want to destroy his race it all boils
down to what happened to his little
brother Ronnie earlier in the film we
hear that Ronnie was killed by what's
heavily implied is a white cop who left
him to die in the pavement after being
shot without calling an ambulance thus
old Fontaine has this warped idea that
by working with the government he'd be
preventing injustices like this from
happening through a process he calls
assimilation assimilation is better than
he would rather assimilate his people
rather than see them annihilated now the
government wants to quote win the race
of the future which we can see printed
on the side of the golf carts
underground a cheeky play on words with
race here having two meanings Kiefer
Sutherland's character who is the main
Baddie of the film says that's what we
strive for
keeping the United States United but
what he's really saying is keep the
United States white I also think it's
ironic that his racist character is
named Nixon and is played by a Canadian
up until now the project of creating
controlled communities through drugs
music and products was merely a Band-Aid
solution to keep people of color
contained this process needed the use of
specific clones and it's important to
note that not everyone in town is a
clone just key players instrumental in
dealing out the products to keep these
communities obedient whether it be
Fontaine and Slick Charles through laced
cocaine a hair stylist through perm
creams or the Reverend with his tainted
blood of Christ and you know what he
wants most out of each and every one of
you
obedience
and if you're not getting your dose of
obedience through some delicious goddamn
Fried Chicken the government is
continually experimenting on new methods
including music that can turn you from
violent to Peaceful as I said these are
Band-Aid solutions for control what old
Fontaine has found a permanent solution
through something he calls genetic
assimilation it's not enough to think
the same
we have to be the same his work in
genetics allowed him to separate 378
unique genes that separated himself from
white people Asians and Latinos thus
through generations he could slowly
assimilate people of color into white
people hence the tubes of black to white
human specimens in his office we saw
some early test versions of this with
the afro-dawning lab tech and chicken
shop manager Fontaine stumbles upon his
clone in the duplication chamber and
Finds Its number is a001 suggesting he
was the first clone which would make
sense if he's based off its creator but
there are other fontaines such as a
Nixon's driver slash bodyguard Chester
Chester is super obedient and Fontaine
actually uses his code word Olympia
Black the same code Nixon used to
control Fontaine to shoot and kill his
creator the attack on the Underground
compound is a success with all the
Clones set free Fontaine even says he'll
come to start a new life with yo-yo and
Charles in Memphis but just when it
seemed this story is done Fontaine wakes
up just like he did after he died back
in his bed but you'll start to notice
some immediate differences like the
tattoos and haircut we aren't in the
Glenn anymore this looks like it could
be Los Angeles we get the big palm trees
and Ellie Laker Flags in his home like
the Glen however is his daily routine
where we can see him weightlifting going
to the convenience store and pouring the
homeless man a drink there's even a
quick gang sign flashed by this kid
suggesting he could be part of the
Bloods or Crips but it's when the news
comes on that we see a clone of Fontaine
on the screen now we purposely do not
know if this report is coming from the
Glenn just as the announcer is about to
say where we are a cough muffles the
location even in the closed captioning
we don't get to see where this is Nixon
did tell us that the government has
experiments all around the country
including Los Angeles and Detroit so
either what we're seeing here is more of
the Glenn or another location that
managed to escape you may have even
noticed some Crunch cereal on the table
here the same cereal found in the Glen
the government used to control its
subjects and the last line of the film
is ain't that you Tyrone so the Los
Angeles version of Fontaine is Tyrone
hence why the film is called they cloned
Tyrone but now I want to hear what you
thought of the Clone Tyrone give me your
thoughts and theories in the comments
below thanks for watching everyone
please make sure to like And subscribe
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on Twitter and Instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember I met one of my
foot Specialists or myself before my
match listen they look wonderful
foreign